during Monday's congressional hearing
with the FBI director James Comey
Connecticut Congressman Jim Himes
correctly pointed out that there's
almost an endless list of people that
Donald Trump is willing to attack
personally for their positions for their
actions for their statements think about
how long that list is almost everybody
is on the list of people that Donald
Trump has been willing to attack but
who's missing from that list Russian
President Vladimir Putin not on the list
of people that President Trump has been
willing to attack take a look at this
clip but mr. Comey if I can use your
phrase intense public interest there is
intense public interest in the fact that
our new president will attack anyone and
everyone he will attack the cast of
Hamilton he will attack Chuck Schumer he
will attack our allies Mexico Australia
Germany he will attack the intelligence
community which you lead associating you
with McCarthyism and with Nazism but
there's one person and one country which
is immune which is inoculated from any
form of presidential attack no matter
what the behavior no matter if there's a
violation of the INF nuclear treaty no
matter if Vladimir Putin kills political
opponents right president defend
obfuscates does not attack congressmen
Himes is absolutely right and I
challenge anyone in our audience to come
up with an instance of Donald Trump
saying anything explicitly negative
about Russia or Vladimir Putin during
the 2016 election or during his
presidency there's one thing that people
may think of and I'm telling you right
now it's bogus which is there was a time
when Trump was asked about whether it
would be okay for Russia to interfere in
our elections and Trump responded it
wouldn't be okay for anyone to interfere
in our elections that's a very weak
example if that's your strongest example
of Trump criticizing Putin then
congressman Himes is absolutely right
and there's a fine line between
repairing relations with Russia which
has been talked about and fawning over
Russia and refusing to acknowledge any
wrongdoing on their part in any
situation remember that this is Donald
Trump's attitude Putin's a killer
a lot of killers got a lot of killers
well you think our country's so innocent
right
Vladimir Putin invades countries for
territorial gains very good reason to
believe that he has had political
opponents shot poisoned with some
regularity and yet and yet take a listen
to this
do you like Vladimir Putin's comments
about you sure when people called you
brilliant that though is good especially
when the person heads up Russia yeah
well I mean also as a person that kills
journalists political ally political
opponents and makes countries and
invades countries obviously that would
be concern with it not he's running this
country and at least he's a leader you
know unlike what we have in this country
wow yeah again he killed journalists
that don't agree with him well I think
our country does plenty of killing also
Joe the world right now Joe a lot of
killing going on a lot of stupidity Wow
Wow
part of that killing and stupidity I
hope Trump would now acknowledge would
be that botched raid in Yemen that led
to 30 civilians including kids being
killed
Putin kills journalists says Jost
Republican Joe Scarborough Trump
responds yeah well he's a great leader
so I respect him remember when the New
York Times released that article of the
319 people places and things that Donald
Trump has insulted on Twitter yeah that
list has everything it's everything from
John McCain to Ronda Rousey and it has
foreign countries it has world leaders I
looked through that again today
no sign of Vladimir Putin no sign of the
Russian government is the average Trump
supporter aware of just how kleptocratic
and murderous Vladimir Putin actually is
would this affect how bothered they
would be about the president being so
friendly with Russia it's almost like
Republicans have chosen to forget
everything that Mitt Romney said about
Putin and Russia four years ago which at
the time they seemed to mostly agree
with and of course Trump isn't the only
one many of the people Trump surrounds
himself with also have really strange
and close ties to Russia tend to mislead
the American people about those ties and
Congressman Himes also astute
during Monday's hearing called attention
to that and the people around the
president Michael Flynn Jeff Sessions
Carter Paige Paul Manafort have an odd
connection to Russia a series of odd
connections we all campaign I don't
think any of our campaign people have
connections with a foreign power much
less one that is an adversary of the
United States and further apart from
these weird links without exception the
individuals I quoted have dissembled or
mislead maybe even lied about the nature
of those convicted those connections
until the political pressure has gotten
to a point where they have been fired or
recused in the case of the Attorney
General do you think Pat that the FBI
investigation into the Trump Russia
stuff going public will finally start to
affect how Russian how Republicans
rather perceive the Trump Russia thing
no because now they'll just label FBI
director Comey as a Trump hater even
though he did he seems to have gone out
of his way to help Trump win the
election by publicizing that they were
investigating Hillary Clinton's emails
over and over again on the other hand
it's still interesting to me how
emotionally unfazed everybody including
me seems to be by the FBI announcing
that the President of the United States
is being investigated because whether so
there's sort of two camps there's the
camp iemon which is I've been aware of
what's been going on with Russia now for
months and months and it would be
obvious to me that there's an
investigation going on so when FBI
director Comey announced it I was
unfazed because obviously there should
be an investigation going on on the
other hand Republicans when they heard
this were probably already unfazed prior
to that because they're just writing the
entire thing off as a fake news witch
hunt meant to take down Trump so they
for other reasons maybe also didn't
react that strongly to the confirmation
I mean even if the smoking gun comes out
pretty soon that the Trump campaign did
collude with the Russian government to
help get him elected yeah I don't think
he would even be that surprised because
every piece was in motion there right
and yes that would be a huge story
everyone would be covering it but we
would be like yeah we saw this coming a
while ago you think Trump is scared of
Putin and that's part of why he doesn't
criticize him I mean that Russian
blackmail file many aspects of it has
been confirmed we still don't know how
much Russia may have
on Trump right I mean we're speculating
of course but a lot of people point out
that maybe there's a contradiction
between Trump and Russia colluding and
Russia having blackmail over Trump I
don't think that's the case because
Putin could have said hey work with me
I'll help get you elected or else I have
this blackmail file so a lot of a lot of
stuff going on here that is very
concerning scandal of the highest order
we're on reddit david pakman.com slash
re d di t discuss this story with us or
any others of interest Gamefly is sort
of like netflix for video games they
have over 8,000 new and classic games
for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s